[Musique]
comment vit un dictateur à quoi
ressemble le quotidien d'un assassin qui
a le pouvoir de vie et de mort sur des
millions de
personnes quelles sont les habitudes les
obsessions les caprices de ces hommes
capables de soumettre tout un monde
population à leur
folie destructrice une journée dans la vie d'un dictateur
offre un regard attentif sur la vie intime
des trois dictateurs les plus meurtriers
du 20e
siècle Staline le dictateur totalitaire
calculatrice froide et méthodique ID au milieu du
dictateur impulsif brutal et
superstitieux mamar Kadhafi  le
Tyran ultriche un
mégalomane dépravé nous les verrons
vivre avec leurs femmes leurs Maîtresses
leurs complices leurs assassins en
pénétrant pour la première fois dans
leurs forteresses leurs maisons leurs
chambres au coeur de leur
vie intime nous avons accédé à ces
espaces hautement privés  que nous avons filmé puis
reconstitué grâce aux nouvelles technologies
puis nous avons introduit des acteurs pour jouer les
rôles des
dictateurs mais aussi pour la première fois dans
un documentaire historique nous avons intégré
les dictateurs eux-mêmes avec des images
tirées d'archives en direct
nous avons ainsi recréé des
scènes réelles  dans la vie quotidienne de ces
trois dictateurs reconstituée dans leurs
décors d'origine la reconstitution de ces trois
jours historiques a également été réalisée
avec l'aide d'historiens et
des entretiens exclusifs des dictateurs
Entourage et des membres de leurs
familles
il avait peur que quelque chose puisse arriver
à son  dans la vie les gens avaient peur de lui
et lui aussi avait peur de ce
peuple [Musique] [Applaudissements] nous allons donc entrer dans les coulisses du
pouvoir absolu et nous vivrons à notre
heure une journée cruciale pour les trois
dictateurs à un tournant de  leur
Règne trois jours décisifs trois
visages différents de la dictature pour
comprendre comment la soif de pouvoir d'un seul homme
peut briser le destin de
tout un
peuple [Musique] Union Soviétique jeudi 24 novembre
[Musique]
à quelques kilomètres au sud de Moscou Le
Courrier du Kremlin a  vient
de remettre les dépêches aux
données de Staline incroyablement paranoïaque Staline vit
caché au milieu de la
forêt sa résidence est protégée par
des batteries anti-aériennes et une
force de sécurité de 300
soldats personne n'est autorisé à entrer dans
la ducha sans l'autorisation spécifique du dictateur
seulement Valentina  son gouvernement a le
droit d'accès
chaque matin comme d'habitude elle
lui apporte ses dépêches à 7 heures du matin
le dictateur est toujours
debout il a passé toute la nuit à vérifier une
liste qui condamne
3 178 personnes à mort ou à la déportation
une tâche longue et laborieuse qui  est loin
d'être terminé mais Staline est un homme méticuleux
il prend son temps à cocher un à un les noms
des Condamnés sur
ordinateur à 60 ans et au sommet de son
pouvoir il contrôle tout il mène une
vie austère rien ne l'intéresse Au delà d'
exercer son propre pouvoir
non Staline a régné sur l'URSS pendant
10 ans composée de 15 républiques l'
Union des républiques socialistes soviétiques
occupe 16 des terres émergées du monde
et s'étend sur 11 fuseaux horaires c'est le
plus grand empire de tous
les temps à ce stade de sa vie il est  un
homme froid et insensible Staline, le nom
qu'il a choisi pendant la
révolution russe signifie l'homme d'
acier
Staline est le dictateur totalitaire ultime,
il est convaincu qu'il a été
choisi par la Providence pour transformer la
société et construire un communisme mondial idéal,
il veut créer l'homme nouveau
discipliné, obéissant, travailleur et
aveuglément obéissant au parti signifiant à
[Musique]
Staline
pour accomplir ce projet colossal
Staline doit tout détruire avant de
pouvoir le reconstruire éradiquer tous les privilèges
éliminer tous les traîtres et si nécessaire
il est prêt à exterminer la moitié de
la
population pendant un an  et demi il a
mis en place un système scientifique d'
élimination massive qui s'appelle la
Grande
Purge
[Musique]
entre juillet 1937 et novembre 1938
il a fait exécuter 800 000 Russes
1 500 victimes par jour, une toutes les 57
secondes
[Musique]
fin novembre 1938 Staline a
atteint le pouvoir absolu, il a
exterminé tous ses ennemis
réels ou imaginaires, il est temps d'arrêter le
bain de sang avant que son peuple ne réalise qu'il
n'est qu'un
fou meurtrier pour s'absoudre de toute culpabilité que
Staline accusera le chef  de la
police secrète Nikolai yov L'homme connu
comme le nain assoiffé de sang pour avoir
commis ces crimes dans son dos
yov lui obéit comme un chien et a
torturé et assassiné de
ses propres mains des milliers d'innocents, bientôt
ce sera son tour d'affronter la torture et
Mort Staline vous a convoqué à son
bureau à 18
heures.  il est 7h30. Staline a enfin
terminé sa charge de travail quotidienne de 16 heures, il
s'allonge sur le canapé de son bureau et
dort paisiblement quelques heures avant de
mettre son plan à
exécution car il dit lui-même que le plus grand
des plaisirs est de choisir son  victime
prépare son coup pour se venger
puis se
couche Libye vendredi 28 juin
Muar Kadhafi, le guide de la
révolution libyenne se réveille dans la luxueuse
chambre d'une de ses nombreuses villas il
est 8h00 et comme chaque matin
Kadhafi a du mal à se réveiller
Contrairement à la vie austère de Staline, il est
totalement dominé par ses pulsions et
souffre de nombreuses addictions aux
drogues psychotropes, à la cocaïne, à l'alcool et
au sexe,
mais à 54 ans, son corps s'use après
avoir été soumis à toutes sortes d'
excès pendant bien trop longtemps.
Il lui est de plus en plus difficile de
maintenir sa maîtrise de soi en public. Les
gens sont souvent perplexes face à son
comportement erratique. Miton le jugeait instable.
Ronald Reagan le qualifiait de
chien fou et, pour Anir Al Sadat, il était tout simplement fou.
[Musique]
fou
[Musique].
néanmoins, c'est ce maniaque du sexe et
toxicomane qui dirige la Libye d'une
main de fer depuis 27 ans. Il
pille systématiquement les richesses de son pays. En
commençant par confisquer les
revenus colossaux du pétrole et du gaz, puis en
s'appropriant toutes les affaires du grand capital
et en les redistribuant aujourd'hui à son
entourage, même si  il est l'un des
hommes les plus riches du monde sa maison est
à moitié enterrée sous terre entourée de
murs pare-balles et de tours de guet avec des
soldats qui montent la garde 24 heures sur 24
non seulement fait partie de cette résidence sous
terre mais elle est également cachée à l'intérieur
du périmètre d'un lieu ultra sécurisé  le
complexe Bab Alazia qui couvre 6
kilomètres carrés une ville entière dans une ville
située au cœur de Tripoli une immense
zone entourée de murs une véritable
forteresse moderne Muhammad Gwan Le caméraman personnel de Kadhafi
fait partie du cercle
[musique] le plus intime du dictateur
et même à l'intérieur de cette forteresse  l'
emplacement exact de la maison de Kadhafi est gardé
secret. La
peur des attaques est devenue une obsession pour
Kadhafi après que les Américains ont bombardé son
palais en
1986, soupçonnés d'avoir financé de nombreuses
attaques terroristes à travers le monde qui ont fait des
centaines de victimes. Il est devenu
depuis lors l'ennemi public numéro un.  a vécu constamment
en alerte comme un fugitif à l'intérieur de son
propre
pays, mais maintenant, en 1996, Kadhafi est
menacé par un nouvel ennemi, le
Front national de libération de la Libye,
composé de groupes islamistes armés
basés dans le désert et qui ont
déclaré la guerre.  sur
lui Kadhafi prend cette menace très
au sérieux ce sont des salafistes soupçonnés
d'être liés à Al-
Qaïda il a déjà fait
arrêter et emprisonner des centaines d'entre eux dans la prison d'Abu
Sadim les
conditions de vie sont
horribles fatis triste
y a été emprisonné pendant cette période pendant 12 ans il
J'ai été témoin de ce que les prisonniers devaient
subir,
les conditions à l'intérieur étaient vraiment
brutales, les cellules de la prison étaient
surpeuplées, les personnes qui mouraient étaient
souvent laissées dans les cellules pendant des jours et la
torture était
institutionnelle, les gens avaient l'impression qu'il n'y avait
aucune issue et ils étaient enterrés vivants
dans cette prison.  ils avaient l'impression d'être
dans une prison où les clés avaient été
jetées ce vendredi 28 juin les
ERS de la prison n'en peuvent plus ils ont atteint
leur limite depuis des jours les cadavres ont
été laissés pourrir dans leurs cellules ils n'ont
rien à
perdre aujourd'hui Kadhafi  devra bientôt faire
face à une situation totalement inédite
en 27 ans de pouvoir absolu
il n'a jamais eu à affronter le genre de
révolte massive qui est sur le point d'
éclater à Abou Salim cette date ne sera jamais
oubliée dans l'histoire sanglante de la Libye
sous Kadhafi
gouverner l'
Ouganda mardi 26 mars
[Musique] [
Musique]
e
ce matin mardi 26 mars 1974 mon esprit
se réveille à nouveau d'un cauchemar
des tueurs essayaient de l'assassiner
chez lui pendant la nuit et ces
tueurs étaient ses propres
soldats comme Kadhafi et Staline il
dort très peu pour ces
hommes paranoïaques la nuit fait ressortir leurs pires peurs
surtout pour Amin dat qui vit dans un
monde irrationnel où les esprits de
ses ennemis morts viennent le hanter et
cherchent à
se venger en plus il y a des peurs qui ne
sont que trop réelles 3 ans  il y a quelques années, en tant que général de l'armée,
il a réussi à renverser son
prédécesseur par un
kudeta. Maintenant, il a lui-même peur d'être
renversé pour maintenir le pouvoir et se protéger.
Il a déclenché un règne de
terreur dans tout le pays. Tout rêve
jugé prémonitoire peut entraîner des
centaines d'arrestations.  et d'exécutions
le même jour, il avait peur que
quelque chose puisse arriver dans sa vie
parce que comment il
était, comment il
dirigeait, les gens avaient peur de lui et
aussi il avait peur des
gens. Tout le monde est soumis à la
répression à commencer par ses plus proches
collaborateurs. Qui  commencent à disparaître les uns
après les autres, tout le monde en
Ouganda, les membres de la
police des forces armées et le
public, ils sont responsables de ma
sécurité et immédiatement ils entendent
quiconque se livrer à des activités subversives ou
essayer de planifier quoi que ce soit contre moi, ils
signalent cette personne directement à la
police et à la police.  Les méthodes employées par la
police d'Amin sont extrêmement brutales. Les
victimes sont matraquées à mort, brûlées dans
la savane, leurs corps jetés aux
crocodiles du Nil ou abattues en public,
vêtues de tabliers blancs pour mettre en valeur le
sang étouffé avec leur propre pénis
fourré dans la gorge et certains même
dynamités dans
en 3 ans il a déjà fait
massacrer plus de 150 000 ougandais mais contrairement à Staline et Kadhafi
Amin participe personnellement à la repr
sa maison est située à seulement quelques mètres
du principal Centre de détention
et
de torture pour entrer sans être vu Amin
a eu un tunnel  construit, il torture
lui-même les victimes et
les achève ensuite généralement avec un
marteau. Aman se méfie de
tout le monde et surtout de son
entourage. Sa fille se souvient de la façon dont il
passait des nuits à surveiller ses propres
soldats. Il ne dormait pas tellement il
peut dormir surtout.  pendant la journée mais
pendant la nuit, il peut juste être là sur
le balcon, il éteint la lumière et
regarde les soldats comment ils
cinglent, tu connais un endroit comme la State House,
car il y a des buissons, tellement d'arbres, des
choses comme ça, il doit avoir peur,
tu dois aussi avoir peur.  vos propres
soldats parce qu'il pensait qu'en tant
qu'état-major, ils pouvaient lui faire
du mal, voyez-vous et c'était exact, ils
lui ont dit que les gens qui vont
vous renverser sont ceux avec qui vous
travaillez, c'est pourquoi lorsque vous êtes
président, ne le faites pas  faites confiance aux gens qui les aiment,
mais ne leur faites pas confiance
comme Staline et Kadhafi Amin avait
pris le pouvoir par la force. Tous les
dictateurs étaient pris dans la même
spirale de violence, ils se méfiaient
de tout le monde et ne pouvaient faire confiance à
personne, en particulier à leurs proches.  eux
qui étaient les mieux placés pour
les assassiner à cause de cette pression énorme
ils plongeraient progressivement dans la
folie et la
paranoïa il ne le sait pas encore mais
aujourd'hui ID Amin a de bonnes raisons d'avoir
peur
[Musique]
son ​​propre cousin le Général arub avec qui il a
grandi  et qu'il avait nommé
général de brigade de l'armée
envisage de
le renverser car il dira plus tard à son fils Jafar
Ain qu'il était sur le point de vivre le
jour le plus difficile de son
règne, la question de la tentative de poussée de
sa propre tribu, le  Kaka nous sommes kakas
c'était la situation la plus
douloureuse pour mon père Charles
arub était plus ou moins un
frère en tant que cousin il était vraiment un
frère en plus de toutes les
atrocités qu'il a commises maintenant je vais
devoir aller plus loin et aller à l'
encontre  un membre de sa propre
famille
il est 10h00 Staline a dormi à peine
3 heures malgré son immense popularité
le petit père des peuples
vénérés par le monde entier vit comme
un loup solitaire dans son immense
ducha La Villa dispose de plusieurs
salons et  une douzaine de chambres
qui restent vides et où il ne
remet plus
les pieds depuis le suicide de sa femme il y a 6 ans
Staline s'est totalement isolé
même si autrefois entouré d'
amis et de belle-famille, aujourd'hui il n'y a
qu'une seule personne en qui il a confiance, sa
gouvernante
Valentina, elle est  celle qui s'occupe de
lui
[Musique]
quotidiennement fidèle illettrée naïve
toujours de bonne humeur elle ne
s'intéresse absolument pas à la
politique elle partage aussi secrètement le
lit du dictateur cette relation
durera jusqu'à sa
mort
Valentina est la seule personne qui connaît
toutes les faiblesses du dictateur  Derrière son
image de leader invulnérable, Staline
a une santé fragile et souffre d'
infections chroniques de la gorge, de psoriasis et de
sclérose artérielle qui nécessitent
des traitements quotidiens.
[Musique] [
Musique] [
Musique]
Avant, Staline vit seul avec Valentina,
mais auparavant, il avait été marié
deux fois.  sa première femme est décédée d'une maladie
quand elle était très jeune, sa seconde épouse
Nadia a eu deux enfants avec
[Musique]
Staline de son vivant, les deux
familles recomposées venaient souvent à la ducha
pour
pique-niquer, c'étaient des moments heureux [
Musique]
mais en 1932, Nadia  s'est
suicidée en se tirant une balle dans le Coeur
pendant 13 ans de mariage elle a
progressivement découvert qui était réellement l'homme qu'elle a
épousé
jusqu'au bout par loyauté envers
son mari Nadia a gardé sa souffrance pour
elle mais avant de se suicider
elle l'a confiée à son frère  et les
parents de sa belle-sœur Alexandre,
en parlant du suicide de sa femme,
Staline avait l'habitude de dire qu'elle m'avait laissé comme un
ennemi, qu'elle m'avait laissé infirme pour le reste
de ma
vie,
c'est cet événement qui a fait
perdre à Staline tout sentiment humain qu'il a commencé à
développer  une haine envers toute sa famille
qu'il a systématiquement
[Musique]
éliminée
et c'est précisément ce jour de
novembre 1938 que la mère d'Evia Alexander
est sur le point de commettre une erreur qui lui
sera
fatale
[Applaudissements]
il est 11h00 à bab
al-azizia  Kadhafi est dans sa salle de bain et
se prépare à commencer la journée. Plusieurs jeunes
femmes sont présentes pour répondre à
tous ses besoins. Elles prennent sa
tension artérielle quotidiennement, elles le massent, se
maquillent et se teignent les cheveux pour couvrir les
zones chauves. [Applaudissements]
mais à 54 ans, Kadhafi peut le faire.  ne supporte pas le
vieillissement prématuré de son visage marqué par
des excès de toutes sortes et qui
ne ressemble en rien au jeune homme qui a pris
le pouvoir il y a 25 ans,
à l'époque la presse internationale
le qualifiait de
Kennedy arabe et sa beauté jouait  un
élément essentiel de sa popularité et de son
succès mais il ne peut plus compter sur ses
charmes de séduction il y a quelques semaines
il a subi pour la
première
fois une chirurgie esthétique cela a eu lieu en pleine
nuit dans une clinique de haute sécurité construite dans
un bunker  sous sa
maison le chirurgien était brésilien, aucun
Libyen n'était présent et Kadhafi a refusé une
anesthésie générale pour rester
conscient pendant l'
opération
[Musique]
ou
toute sa vie Kadhafi continuerait à se faire
faire de la chirurgie plastique sans médecin
généraliste
[Musique]
anesthésie obsédée par son image
Kadhafi se réinvente sans cesse
selon le rôle politique
qu'il souhaite
jouer soldat de la
Révolution patron du
terrorisme international leader autoproclamé des
pays arabes
et même roi des
rois africains il n'y a pas de limite à son  arrogance
et
[Musique]
mégalomanie
[Applaudissements]
pour
[Musique]
Kadhafi venait d'une famille double, ils
vivaient dans une tente dans une zone désertique près
de la ville de Seir, une région considérée comme
presque inhabitable où le jeune Mouamar
gardait les
chèvres, son père travaillait comme domestique  pour
une famille puissante, ils étaient considérés comme
des Libyens de seconde zone. Kadhafi n'oublierait jamais
que la famille de son cousin partageait bien la misère
de son enfance. Tri à l'
époque, il respectait
les forts
et les
riches, il n'était ni fort ni
riche et il avait une
vie difficile et difficile.  le
début, je pense que c'est l'une des
raisons qu'il
invoque contre le peuple,
après que toute
la société soit au plus profond de lui,
c'est sa meilleure
finalité quand il n'avait que 10 ans. Kadhafi
a décidé d'échapper à la pauvreté dans la
vie de sa famille et d'aller à l'école dans la
ville qu'il a gravie  dans un camion et est arrivé
en C seul et sans ressources il a dormi
dehors et a survécu à
des rendez-vous lorsqu'il est revenu dans son village
quelques années plus tard il est revenu en héros il
était devenu le colonel Kadhafi l'homme qui venait de
mener la révolution et de libérer
son peuple  la monarchie du vieux roi
Idris qui avait régné pendant 52
ans depuis le début Kadhafi savait comment
mettre en valeur ce scénario d'enfance à son
avantage en organisant des interviews avec sa
famille pour des programmes de télévision libyens qui
seront ensuite repris par les
chaînes étrangères où il a joué L'Homme humble.
qui doit tout à son fort
caractère et à son
courage
[Musique]
25 ans plus tard Kadhafi et sa famille
contrôlaient toutes les raffineries et étaient
à la tête de toutes les plus grandes entreprises
du
pays [Musique] ce n'est qu'après sa mort que son
peuple apprendra que  l'humble conjoint et
ses enfants avaient vécu dans le
luxe absolu à la fin de sa vie, sa
fortune personnelle était estimée à 144
milliards de dollars, le petit berger du désert était
devenu l'un des hommes les plus riches du
monde
[Musique] [
Musique]
[Musique]
Amin Dada  a également pillé son
pays, il collectionne les voitures de luxe et
dépense des sommes d'argent illimitées, il est
rarement dans son bureau et passe une
grande partie de son temps dans ses villas
en compagnie de ses
maîtresses. Ils avaient tellement d'épouses que vous
voyez la plupart des maisons où elle  si elle devait
avoir une femme
là-bas, on estime qu'Amin dat aurait eu
au moins 40 enfants, mais même Babi
Salamida, la fille de l'une de ses
trois épouses légitimes, ne se souvient pas
exactement du nombre de frères et sœurs
qu'elle avait, nous restons avec mes six pour
celui qui est mort euh quatre encore
huit, laissez-moi vous
dire que je pense que
22 ans après 3 ans de
pouvoir absolu, Amin peut enfin avoir tout ce dont
il a été privé dans son enfance, mon
père venait du niveau le plus bas de la
communauté et il disait simplement que je '  Je suis
un exemple de pur Cropper, quelqu'un
qui avait l'habitude de couper la canne à sucre lorsqu'il était enfant
et qui est devenu chef d'État. Il est donc possible qu'il ait vécu l'ère coloniale et qu'il soit
arrivé au pouvoir de façon inattendue, mais il
avait servi et vécu l'ère coloniale.
]
ère Amin appartenait à la tribu Kaka Une
tribu vivant dans une région désertique reculée
de l'Ouganda. Son père a abandonné la
famille quand Amin était encore très jeune. Sa
mère pratiquait la sorcellerie. Elle a
élevé son fils seule dans un
monde irrationnel dominé par les esprits pour
survivre.  a emménagé avec un soldat du
régiment colonial britannique mais les autres soldats de la
base ont continué à la narguer et ont finalement chassé
elle et son fils.
Les deux ont vécu dans une misère totale jusqu'à ce qu'Amin
n'ait d'autre choix que de s'inscrire dans
le régiment même qui l'avait humilié.
lui
à 18 ans il n'était qu'un garçon de cuisine mais il
gravit rapidement les
échelons quelques années plus tard il devint l'un
des seuls officiers noirs de l'
armée coloniale qui avait remarqué la force et le
potentiel de
violence d'Amin chargé de réprimer les
révoltes des Rebelles  tribus auxquelles il est revenu
Tactiques de terreur et
torture ce sont les méthodes qu'il a utilisées
pour couper les organes génitaux des coupables
et les humilier
après l'indépendance et le
départ des Britanniques en 1962 Amin
poursuit son ascension et devient
commandant de l'armée ougandaise sous le
président Milton  abuti mais son ambition
ne s'arrête pas là après plusieurs
tentatives d'assassinat il
réussit finalement à renverser obote et
prend le pouvoir le 25 janvier
[Musique]
1971 il
n'était pas bien éduqué
mais il avait beaucoup
d'intelligence naturelle et euh
il a réussi à manœuvrer son  à la
grande stupéfaction de
ceux qui étaient avec
lui, maintenant, c'est Amin qui a le
pouvoir que vous avez dit que vous vouliez enseigner,
écrit une leçon au président, pourquoi cela
signifie-t-il la fin de
votre amitié avec la Grande-Bretagne et c'est maintenant  la leçon que
j'enseigne aux Britanniques avec une certaine
ironie il trouve des moyens provocateurs pour
humilier ses anciens maîtres il
oblige les hommes d'affaires britanniques à s'agenouiller et à
lui déclarer allégeance il fait porter son
trône par quatre
hommes blancs il va même jusqu'à accorder une
armée britannique officielle  médailles sur
lui-même afin de vous faire comprendre clairement que
j'ai été honoré par le
plus haut ordre de Conquérant de l'
impérialisme britannique en
Ouganda [Applaudissements] Sans aucun scrupule, Amin s'invente les
titres les plus fantastiques, il se
proclame président pour Life
King  d'Ecosse et sa mégalomanie
atteignant des proportions délirantes
Seigneur de tous les animaux du monde et
de tous les poissons de la
mer à 1 M 95 125 kilos est une
véritable force de la nature un Colosse qui
submerge tout le monde par son
physique hors du commun et son sens du spectacle
le rendent très
populaire dès le début les caméras
du monde entier sont braquées sur
cet individu excentrique et imprévisible
qui ne craint pas d'être
interviewé dans sa piscine en
pyjama Je fais de la politique et du sport B et
même même des tactiques sont utilisées dans le
sport par  assommer les gens se servent de la
politique dans sa jeunesse Amin a été
champion de boxe d'Ouganda huit fois de suite
Amin est l'homme le plus fort du pays
il est Big Daddy rassurant et
effrayant à la fois et si ses
excentricités amusaient son peuple dans les
médias ils servaient aussi  comme
écran pour ses
crimes [musiques], il est 12h30.  Amin vient
d'apprendre quelque chose qui l'a rendu
furieux ses trois femmes ont fait
la fête toute la nuit avec leurs gardes du corps
négligés par leur mari elles voulaient
le provoquer mais n'auraient pas pu
imaginer le risque qu'elles prenaient Amin
ne tolérera pas cette insulte et
décide de le prendre  par
vengeance il se précipite à la radio
pour révéler à tout le pays le comportement indécent de sa
femme
il crie mes femmes sont
infidèles elles m'ont trahi elles
ont détruit mon travail politique je
les répudie je divorce
aujourd'hui même elles doivent quitter la
maison le  en entendant ces déclarations les
trois épouses se dépêchent de faire leurs valises
et s'enfuient de la maison pour échapper à ma
colère méchante lorsqu'elles rentrent de l'école
les enfants ne comprennent pas ce qui
se passe je
me souviens que nous nous préparons à rentrer à la
maison alors quand nous sommes revenus de l'école nous
J'ai découvert que toutes ma mère et mes belles-mères
n'étaient pas à la maison, puis elles nous ont dit
avec la femme de ménage où est maman, elles ont dit
non, elles ont emballé leurs affaires, elles
sont parties donc nous avons été
choqués, voyez-vous, et même vous ne pouviez
même pas  demande à notre père parce qu'en plus il
nous regardait nous avions peur de
demander ouais nous sommes à
l'école quelques mois plus tard la mère de malamu bab
a été grièvement blessée dans un accident elle
a réussi à s'échapper de l'Ouganda et à se
réfugier à
Londres sa fille n'a pas voulu  la revoir
depuis plus de 30
ans Nora a été épargnée pour des
raisons politiques elle appartient à une tribu que Amin
persécute il l'épargne pour
se décharger de toute
responsabilité Kay n'aura pas autant de chance
un an plus tard elle a été retrouvée coupée en morceaux
dans le coffre  d'une
voiture les enfants ont découvert cette
horreur à la télévision où nous jouions
alors ils nous ont appelés pour aller prendre
une douche puis nos sœurs sont arrivées en courant ont
dit je t'avais dit de venir la télévision m
Sachez que M aussi est
morte donc la sœur ma sœur K est  le
premier né de M elle a commencé à
pleurer
puis elle a été coupée en
morceaux c'était très dur c'était très dur
pour nous c'était quelque chose
d'étrange c'est le Ministre de la Santé
lui-même qui a reçu l'ordre de je veux dire de
recoudre le corps de la victime
il  a ordonné que le corps soit recousu,
les parties soient recousues comme elles auraient dû l'
être, ce que nous avons fait à
l'
hôpital, les enfants ont dû aller voir
le corps de leur
mère, une expérience très traumatisante car
pour eux à cet
âge,
Amin prend  profite de l'événement pour une
exposition de maabo, il expose le corps recousu de Kay
devant l'hôpital
à la vue de toute la foule et force même
ses propres enfants à le regarder devant
tout le monde, il crie que ta mère, tu
vois, était une femme lâche  regarde ce qui
s'est passé, voici comment sont punis ceux qui blasphèment
contre Allah.
Babby Salamida se souvient encore du
moment où elle a vu ses demi-frères
et sœurs rentrer de l'hôpital,
ils pleuraient juste
mécontents, ils ne jouent plus avec
nous et parfois ils disent que
notre mère nous manque pour toi tu as ta mère
pour nous nous n'en avons pas nous nous n'en avons plus
[Musique]
mère
il est 13h.  dans son bureau Staline
reçoit Evia sa belle-soeur
venue lui rendre une visite inattendue Evia
est la sœur de sa seconde épouse Nadia
celle qui s'est
suicidée depuis cet événement tragique Staline
déteste toute sa belle-famille
il reçoit de l'eia
froidement Evia a peur qu'une partie de sa
famille ait déjà été exécutée ou envoyée
au goulag par Staline elle le soupçonne même d'
être responsable de l'empoisonnement de son
mari quelques jours plus tôt pourtant
malgré le danger Evia est venue lui remettre
une lettre de Maria une autre  de la
belle-sœur de Staline qu'il a envoyée au
goulag sans raison apparente les
conditions de vie dans les goulags de Staline en
Sibérie sont terribles, jusqu'à 50° en dessous de
zéro en hiver une journée de travail de 12 heures pas
assez de
nourriture les prisonniers meurent de faim froide et
d'épuisement  et
[Musique]
le désespoir de son Goulag Maria a réussi
à obtenir une lettre à sa belle-sœur
suppliant Staline de la libérer,
écrit-elle si je ne sors pas de ce
camp, je mourrai
ici plusieurs années plus tard Evia a décrit le
scène à son fils
Alexandre
mais en fait Staline détestait tout plaidoyer en faveur
de ceux qu'il avait classés une fois pour
toutes comme ses ennemis. Non seulement Maria
ne serait pas libérée, mais elle serait transférée dans
un camp encore pire et
exécutée plusieurs mois
plus tard et depuis  Staline n'a jamais oublié une
insulte, il riposterait contre Evia
en l'envoyant au goulag quelques années
plus tard, presque toute la famille de Staline a été
victime de sa folie meurtrière. Le
frère de sa seconde épouse Nadia a été
empoisonné le 2 novembre
1938. Evia, sa femme et Kira  leur
fille envoyée au goulag en
1947 Anna la sœur aînée de la
première épouse de Staline 6 ans dans le
goulag son mari Stanislav fusillé le
12 février
1940 Alexandre le frère de sa première femme
fusillé le 20 août
1941 sa femme Maria et sa sœur Mao
fusillées ensemble  en mars
1942 sans compter tous ses amis proches
disparus les uns après les
autres
Staline lui-même grandit dans une
atmosphère familiale d'insécurité et de violence il
était le seul survivant de trois enfants
son père cordonnier était alcoolique
et battait régulièrement son fils il mourut quand
Staline avait 10 ans sa mère une femme de ménage
remarqua très tôt son intelligence et
réussit à l'inscrire dans un séminaire pour qu'il
devienne prêtre un
élève brillant il fera huit années d'
études avant d'être expulsé à cause de
ses idées subversives il venait
alors de découvrir le marxisme  Il s'est
passionnément engagé dans la
lutte révolutionnaire contre le Zar.
Staline a tué des gens de ses propres mains
et est devenu le chef d'un gang bolchevique
qui a volé les banques, pillé les villages et
planifié des assassinats pour financer le
parti de Lennon lorsque les bolcheviks sont arrivés au pouvoir.
Lénine a fait de lui l'un des  Les hauts
responsables du parti néanmoins, avant sa mort,
Lenon voulait l'empêcher de
devenir son successeur dans son testament, il
écrirait que Staline est beaucoup trop brutal, il
faut l'empêcher de prendre
le pouvoir d'un point de vue clinique.
Joseph Staline Amin dat et Mouamar
Kadhafi avaient tous le droit  trois
caractéristiques d'un psychopathe ils ont tous
souffert de la violence, de la misère et de l'
humiliation qu'ils ont vécues dans leur enfance
et sont devenus profondément antisociaux ils ont
également souffert de l'absence de
père, une absence physique pour Staline et
Amin qui ont perdu leur père très tôt et
une absence symbolique pour Kadhafi  fils d'un
homme faible et humilié qui
l'a abandonné lorsque les psychopathes sombrent de plus en
plus dans la folie, ils recherchent
les limites qui ne leur ont jamais été imposées
par un père et infliger la mort
à des milliers de personnes est l'
étape ultime pour transgresser ces limites.  limite
[la musique]
comme Staline tous les jours Kadhafi signe les
listes des condamnés à
la prison ou à mort il ne tolère aucun
argument il disait que tous ceux qui
s'opposent au régime et surtout les
islamistes doivent être traités comme des cafards
et méritent d'être éradiqués sans
procès dès son arrivée au pouvoir il a
mis en place un régime brutalement répressif
mais c'est en 1984 après avoir échappé de peu à
une tentative d'assassinat qu'il
décide de téléviser les procès et les
exécutions publiques afin de terrifier
l'ensemble de la population.
celle de ce jeune étudiant jugé
devant une foule en colère et dont le seul
crime était d'avoir étudié
à l'étranger
et le
compagnon d'un tribunal simulé l'accuse d'
avoir pris contact avec des figures de l'
opposition aux Etats-Unis et même de s'être
formé au Maroc pour se préparer  une
tentative d'assassinat contre Kadhafi en espérant lui
sauver la vie l'étudiant avoue
tout mais comme dans tous
les procès pour corruption le résultat est joué d'avance
[Musique]
c'est un événement qui a choqué tous les Libyens
euh parce que je pense que c'est à ce moment-là
qu'ils ont compris à quel point  jusqu'où le
régime de Kadhafi était prêt à aller pour
semer la terreur parmi son propre
peuple, la population entière se sentait
menacée, même les gens au plus haut
niveau
[Musique]
et pourtant Kadhafi était un jeune
révolutionnaire qui a accédé au pouvoir à l'
âge de 27 ans en tant que défenseur de  de grandes
causes pour unifier les pays arabes pour
libérer la Libye de l'occupation étrangère en
nationalisant les
compagnies pétrolières pour restaurer l'indépendance et la
fierté de son pays les libyens le considéraient
comme le grand libérateur un autre Naser
comme Staline et entre autres pour construire la
fierté nationale et parvenir à une plus grande
justice sociale avec  les deux thèmes principaux
qui servent à consolider son
[Applaudissements]
pouvoir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements] [
Musique] [
Applaudissements] [
Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais la lune de miel avec son peuple est
bientôt terminée maintenant il a peur de son peuple
il ne supporte même pas d'être touché par
eux et lorsqu'il est obligé de se mêler
à la foule en faisant semblant d'en
profiter, il frappe ses gardes du corps s'ils
laissent quelqu'un s'approcher de trop
près.
[Musique]
Kadhafi a perdu tout contact avec son
peuple, maintenant il n'est plus qu'à lui  communique avec
eux à la télévision aujourd'hui comme il le fait
plusieurs fois par semaine il
s'apprête à enregistrer un de ses interminables
discours qui fait bâiller la plupart des libyens
[Musique]
mais enfin alors qu'il est sur le point de commencer,
sa secrétaire l'interrompt avec le
la nouvelle qu'une révolte vient d'éclater
à la prison d'Abou Sadim
Kadhafi ne prend pas l'alerte
au sérieux. Abu Salim est une prison de très haute
sécurité et il est convaincu que
ses puissantes forces de police peuvent réprimer
la rébellion, mais ce qui se passe dans
la prison est  bien pire qu'il ne le pense
car
Kadhafi ne se doute pas qu'à l'
instant même ce qui se passe dans la prison
aura des répercussions sans fin jusqu'au
jour où il
mourra
[Musique]
après avoir divorcé de ses trois femmes
ce matin Amin doit maintenant affronter son
cousin le général Charles
Arubi  il veut le voir en personne pour
lire dans ses yeux les signes de trahison
dont il a été prévenu aru
représente tout ce qu'il déteste c'est
un homme élégant et cultivé un
intellectuel qui a été éduqué en
Angleterre il représente une réelle menace pour Amin
car  arubi a le soutien d'une grande
partie de l'armée régulière
la situation est encore plus délicate
car il a affaire à un membre de
sa propre
famille Amin commence par l'accuser
carrément il dit qu'il est au courant du
complot de son cousin et qu'il ne le fera pas  s'en sortir
mais arub reste imperturbable il
n'essaye pas de se défendre il
critique le règne de terreur d'Amin qui
a balayé le pays Amin explose de
colère personne n'a jamais osé le défier
ainsi il est le chef maintenant et si
arub  dit encore une chose contre lui il
peut faire exécuter aru sur
place mais arub reste impassible Amin
se rend compte que son cousin est déterminé
et qu'il a peut-être sous-estimé
sa force sous-jacente il n'a pas le choix
il doit
l'éliminer donc son attitude change il fait semblant
de vouloir  a
Réconciliation il lui dit tu es mon
frère un kakwa comme moi faisons la
paix partons d'ici en paix et que Dieu
te protège
les deux hommes font semblant de se réconcilier mais
ils savent qu'un affrontement armé est
inévitable et qu'à l'issue celui
de  ils
[Musique]
mourront dès qu'Arubi sera sorti de la pièce.
Amin convoque le chef de ses mercenaires
et lui ordonne de rassembler ses hommes pour
poursuivre Arubi et
l'assassiner si lui-même donne l'ordre de vous
éliminer, ils peuvent venir n'importe où.
avec tout le monde qui les regardait, ils
ne s'en soucieraient pas
[Musique] [
Musique]
car tous les jours en début d'après-midi
Staline est au travail dans son bureau au
Kremlin, cette petite pièce est le centre
de l'
Empire aux quatre coins du monde  le
pays des millions de fonctionnaires
fournissent au dictateur toutes les
informations qu'ils peuvent collecter seuls
au sommet d'une immense
pyramide administrative Staline sait tout il est
tout-puissant
pour l'assister dans ce travail colossal il
a quatre secrétaires qui sont de garde 24
heures sur 24  Staline, lointain et méthodique,
procède toujours de la même
manière
car Staline examine
seul en secret la liste des condamnés. Le personnel
du Bureau pour animaux de compagnie ne doit pas savoir que c'est lui
qui condamne ces milliers
d'innocents dont il raye un nom.
de temps en temps un vieux camarade
exilé avec lui en Sibérie lorsqu'il était un
jeune révolutionnaire ou un vieux
bulvik géorgien comme lui quant aux autres une
simple croix en marge suffit pour
les envoyer à la
mort sur cette même liste Staline
ajoute aussi les noms  des personnes qui
travaillent actuellement de l'autre côté de la
salle
pour
[Musique]
pour tous les collaborateurs de Staline ont
été envoyées à travers le pays pour
vérifier que les condamnations à mort ont été
exécutées, une manière pour Staline d'
en faire ses complices qu'ils ne pourraient pas
accuser plus tard  lui des crimes dans lesquels ils
avaient eux-mêmes été impliqués
Anastas Mikan l'un des
principaux ministres de Staline était l'un d'eux son
fils se
souvient que
les familles des Condamnés devaient également
être
éliminées
aujourd'hui, jeudi 24 novembre
1938, Staline vient de signer la dernière
liste  des personnes condamnées à mort lors
de la Grande Purge, il lui reste une dernière chose
à faire : désigner quelqu'un pour assumer
la responsabilité de tous ces
crimes
[Musique]
seulement 3 heures après le début de la
prison d'Abou Salim La révolte a explosé de manière
incontrôlable mais Kadhafi continue  n'a pas
réalisé la gravité de la situation il
retourne dans sa chambre où l'attend une de ses
victimes ces femmes viennent de
toutes les couches de la société elles sont enlevées
à leur famille et amenées devant le
Guide Suprême sans que personne n'ose
protester elles sont maltraitées  pour endurer
les pires humiliations et souvent
[Musique]
battu en 1983 Kadhafi crée une
académie militaire réservée aux femmes qu'il
appelait ses
Amazones elles étaient censées représenter
un aspect de la Libye moderne les guides de
libération des femmes elles sont sa
garde personnelle et l'entourent pendant
toutes ses
apparitions publiques en fait ces amazones
constituent un gigantesque Haram de plus de
400 jeunes femmes à la disposition du dictateur
mais cela ne lui suffit pas
car
un problème pour Kadhafi est survenu lorsqu'une fille
est tombée
enceinte pour résoudre discrètement ce problème il avait
une clinique  construit dans les sous-sol de l'
Université où l'on pouvait pratiquer des avortements
car ainsi des centaines de femmes ont été
violées par Kadhafi par ses fils et même par
ses
hommes Amin attend que ses mercenaires
confirment que son cousin Charles Aru a
été assassiné les enjeux sont
énormes  c'est la tentative de poussée la plus dangereuse
à laquelle il ait jamais eu à faire face
[Musique]
mais il est convaincu qu'il dispose d'une
armée privée de 18 000 hommes qu'il paie en
pillant le
budget de l'État. Ce sont de véritables escadrons de la mort
qui terrifient tout le
pays [Musique]  l'époque d'un moi était une époque de
terreur nous avions peur à cette époque
une grande peur des soldats voir Muhamed
Kisamba était le banquier d'Amin avant d'être
emprisonné comme beaucoup de
collaborateurs des tyrans la méthode pour tuer
les gens était de les frapper à la tête
avec un  Hammer, voyez donc la
population civile était euh terrifiée à cause de
l'acte des
soldats, les gens ont eu
peur
[Musique]
mais cette fois les mercenaires d'Amin ont
échoué, il vient d'apprendre qu'ils
ont été pris en embuscade et tués par les
hommes de son cousin Aru, Charles Arub  et trois
autres camarades
kakas euh ont incité
aita, ils ont pris des postes dans les
domaines clés de la radio télévision et d'
importantes maisons du gouvernement et pensaient
avoir le pouvoir C
[Musique]
Charles aru semble sur le point de
gagner la bataille Amin rassemble ses
troupes pour lancer un  Contre-attaque, je me
souviens de ce jour où notre père est arrivé en
mettant ses revolvers et tout,
puis pour lui, il était au bureau avec
d'autres soldats, donc beaucoup de soldats sont rentrés
chez eux à State House, ils allaient à
la réunion comme quelque chose comme ça, mais nous
pouvions'
nous ne pouvions pas savoir ce qui se passait
autour Amin donne l'ordre à ses mercenaires
d'encercler le bâtiment où
Ruby et ses hommes se sont regroupés et d'
attendre ses ordres avant de
les tuer cet après-midi. Staline a convoqué
Nikolaï yov le  chef de
la police secrète, brillant stratège Staline avait
déjà renoncé au besoin de le sacrifier
au début de la Grande Terreur il y a un an et
demi
il avait tout de suite vu comment se servir de
cet homme cruel surnommé le
nain sanglant un peu aaric prêt à
tout pour conquérir son  La confiance de son maître
avait supervisé les exécutions
dans tout l'Empire et n'avait pas
hésité à torturer et à tuer de ses
propres mains dans la terrible prison de
Lubianka de juillet 1937 jusqu'à aujourd'hui
en novembre 1938. Votre chef de la
Grande Purge sous les ordres de Staline avait
eu 770 000 personnes.  des gens exécutés d'une
balle dans la
tempe pour l'encourager Staline en fit
un des Grands Héros du régime
ses portraits furent portés triomphalement
par la foule il fut applaudi par le
Bureau de la fosse et il partit en vacances avec les
plus hauts dignitaires du
régime mais  aujourd'hui, vous avez peur depuis
quelque temps, il sent sa disgrâce
se rapprocher, la seule chose qu'il espère
sauver, c'est sa propre tête, mais Staline a
signé sa dernière liste de condamnations à mort,
maintenant il a besoin d'un bouc émissaire, il
vous accuse cyniquement des pires crimes qu'il ait commis.  le traite de
rat, de Renégat sanguinaire il
l'accuse d'avoir massacré des centaines
d'innocents dans son dos et
d'être un espion à la solde des
Britanniques, des Allemands et des Japonais il
l'accuse même d'être un alcoolique
un dégénéré et un [ __ ] tout Chef
des accusations qui serviront à le condamner
[Musique]
lui n'essaye même pas de
se défendre il sait qu'une fois que Staline a
décidé de condamner quelqu'un, rien ne peut l'
arrêter son sort est
scellé mais il n'a pas seulement peur pour sa
propre vie il l'est  aussi peur pour sa
fille Natalia qui n'avait que 10
ans lorsqu'il a été arrêté et qui ne savait
rien de ce que son père
[Musique]
avait fait une
seule fois, quand elle avait 6 ans, se
doutait-elle de ce qu'impliquait le travail de son père
Un jour, Natalya a été
confinée dans un orphelinat dans le nord de la
Russie jusqu'à ce qu'elle atteigne
l'âge adulte. Elle n'a découvert ce qui
était arrivé à son père que des années
plus tard, elle n'a plus jamais été autorisée à utiliser le
nom de yov.
Aujourd'hui, elle vit seule dans le même
zone où elle avait été autrefois
[Musique]
déportée une fois l'affaire réglée,
Staline rend visite à ses enfants
comme il le fait chaque
jour, ils sont gardés par une
nounou depuis que leur mère Nadia s'est
suicidée [Musique] Staline passe en revue leurs  devoirs
et signe les cahiers d'école de
swetlana 12 ans et vasili
18 ans Il adore particulièrement sa fille et
est très affectueux envers elle il
prend le temps de jouer avec elle et invente
un jeu dans lequel c'est elle la patronne qui
lui donne des ordres auxquels il obéit avec
plaisir
Butana qui vit dans un cocon remarque
que de nombreux membres de sa famille et
de ses amis ont
disparu, écrirait-elle
mais où sont-ils tous
allés pourquoi notre maison est si
vide de plus en plus j'ai ressenti la
solitude et le vide autour de moi un
monde désertique où mon école  et ma
nounou étaient tout ce qui restait
[Musique]
à l'intérieur du camp C caché
sous sa villa fortifiée. Kadhafi
a fait construire un abri anti-atomique
ainsi qu'un réseau de 40
km de tunnels tous enterrés à 6 M sous la
surface une véritable ville souterraine
avec des chambres  des salons des installations sportives une
clinique et une
télévision Le studio de télévision est son principal outil
de propagande et il supervise lui-même tous les
programmes
pendant qu'il visionne un de ses
discours enregistré quelques heures plus tôt. Son
beau-frère Abdullah Suusi, chef des
renseignements, arrive pour annoncer  la mauvaise
[Musique]
nouvelle plus d'un millier de prisonniers ont
saccagé la prison d'Abu Salim
à coups de masse ils ont forcé l'
ouverture des cellules des bâtiments trois et
quatre ils sont sur le point de s'évader
et les gardiens ne peuvent plus les contenir
Abu Salim contre quatre bâtiments
fattis triste un prisonnier dans le bâtiment 1
où les portes sont restées fermées
décrit ce qui
s'est passé Kadhafi ordonne que les
prisonniers qui ne se sont pas évadés soient
évacués et ordonne à seni de retenir les
barrières l'évacuation prendrait toute
la nuit il est minuit Amin retourne dans sa
chambre tout a  élaboré selon le
plan, Aru pensait que son C était une réussite mais
il fit l'erreur de cesser le combat
et d'aller célébrer la victoire avec
ses hommes dans une des
casernes pendant que les
mercenaires d'Aru se répartissaient tranquillement tout
autour de la zone sans que les troupes d'Aru s'en
rendent compte.  un à un tous les militaires
postés à l'extérieur du bâtiment sont
neutralisés une fois en position les hommes d'Amin l'
informent qu'ils sont prêts à lancer
l'assaut
Amin leur dit d'attendre et parvient à
joindre arub au téléphone à l'intérieur de la
caserne qu'il a appelé Charles
arub et Charles arub  quand il a attrapé
le téléphone, il a senti que le
monsieur était ivre et il semblait
célébrer, ils parlaient au téléphone et les
larmes aux yeux pendant qu'il
me parlait, papa a expliqué cet angle,
il a dit que ma mère t'avait donné  et m'a
dit de prendre soin de toi après tout ça
tu veux me retirer le pouvoir tu
viens me trahir et il pleure je
parle des larmes de mon père donc il
se souvenait d'une chose très douloureuse
Charles Arub a répondu c'est bon
pour Christian  qui est
éduqué pour
gouverner, il a dit Charles
AR regarde par la
fenêtre Charles avait mis son peuple dehors
quand il a regardé dans les positions il
n'a vu aucun de ses gens et il a vu
différents
véhicules il a dit que vous étiez
encerclé
hein quand le téléphone a sonné il  a appelé
l'appel vidéo des gens
à l'extérieur et ils lui ont répondu qu'ils
avaient juste une balle
à l'intérieur, il s'était suicidé, c'est une
vérité douloureuse que parmi nous
les kakas, nous avons dû passer par un
nettoyage culturel parce que les frères s'étaient battus
et que le sang avait
coulé
[Musique  ]
qu'il se soit suicidé ou, plus
probablement, qu'il ait été tué par les hommes d'Amin, Charles
Arub est
mort aujourd'hui. Amin a échappé au PCH le plus
menaçant auquel il ait jamais eu à faire
face [Musique] mais il lui reste une dernière chose
à faire avant d'en
finir définitivement avec Charles
Arub  son corps avait été emmené au
kalala morg Amin doit désormais honorer le rituel du guerrier aaka
[Musique]
si vous goûtez le sang de certaines de
vos victimes alors vous serez protégé
afin d'apaiser l'esprit de ceux
qui ont tué ou de ceux qui  qui a
brutalisé si vous goûtez leur sang,
vous pouvez
amortir votre punition pour lui-même,
croyait à ces
choses, personne n'était présent sur les lieux,
mais il est très probable qu'Amin, selon
ses croyances, a planté un couteau dans le côté d'Aru
pour boire un peu de  son sang et
ainsi capturer son esprit afin qu'il
ne puisse pas se venger
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
après une longue journée bien passée Staline est
allongé sur son vieux canapé en écoutant seul
son morceau préféré, le
concerto pour piano numéro
23 de Mozart, tôt le matin  dans son
immense ducha, le dictateur a toutes
les raisons d'être convaincu qu'en ce 24
novembre 1938, il a éliminé tous ses
ennemis et qu'il est désormais le dirigeant absolu
de l'Union soviétique
[
Musique]
Kadhafi attend la confirmation que
les bâtiments 1 et 2 ont  été évacué
le chef des renseignements lui téléphone
l'évacuation est terminée tous
les prisonniers qui ont émeuté dans
les bâtiments trois et quatre sont maintenant masqués
dans la
cour ils sont enragés la situation
est
explosive il n'y a pas de temps à perdre
Kadhafi ordonne l'exécution des
1 270
prisonniers  il est
8h30, positionnés au sommet des
toits de la prison, les soldats commencent à tirer sur les
prisonniers piégés. Tout
à coup, une force militaire est arrivée et a
littéralement commencé à tirer sur la
prison, tuant plus de 12 200 prisonniers dans un
massacre qui a duré
des heures, ce n'était pas quelque chose de
simple.  en quelques minutes, ils ont continué
à tirer et à tirer et à tirer jusqu'à ce que
presque tout le monde dans ces deux quartiers
soit
mort.
[Musique] En
fin de compte, la disparition de Kadhafi est
très liée à cette décision de commettre un
massacre à Abu Salim U parce qu'il y a
l'étincelle qui  déclenché la révolution
en
2011, en effet, en février 2011, au
plus fort du Printemps arabe, les mères, les
sœurs et les veuves des hommes tués à
Abu Salim descendent dans la rue pour
exiger la vérité exacte sur les
circonstances du
massacre, la police intervient et  tir
sur la foule qui déclenche les premiers
affrontements violents et le début
d'une révolution dans toute la Libye qui
fera rage pendant 9
mois et se terminera par un lynchage de
Kadhafi par son propre
peuple
[Rires]
[Musique]
des années plus tôt dans un de ses textes
Kadhafi  avait
écrit combien j'aime la liberté des foules,
leur esprit enthousiaste après que leurs
chaînes ont été abandonnées, quand ils poussent
un cri de joie et chantent au lieu de
gémir de
tristesse, mais combien je les crains et me méfie d'eux
et combien ils sont cruels lorsqu'ils sont en
colère.  ils ont comploté contre Hannibal et
lui ont fait boire du
poison ils ont brûlé la savola sur le bûcher ont
envoyé Danton à la guillotine fracturé
RIS La mâchoire de Pierre a traîné le corps de Melini
dans les rues cracher au visage de Richard
Nixon
il meurt à l'âge de 69 ans après
avoir régné sur la Libye pendant 42 ans
[  Musique]
années [
Musique]
en 1979, lorsque l'armée tanzanienne a envahi l'
Ouganda. Idam IND a fui vers l'Arabie Saoudite et
y a vécu en exil jusqu'à sa mort. Dans sa
dernière interview, il a dit Je n'ai aucun remords
seulement
Nostalgie, il est mort en 2003 à 75 ans
sans jamais être
poursuivi.  son règne a duré 8 ans,
entraînant la mort de 300 000
personnes aujourd'hui. Le gouvernement ougandais n'est
plus une dictature mais les prisons
et les chambres de torture où des centaines de
milliers de personnes ont été massacrées sont toujours là,
abandonnées dans la
forêt le 1er mars 1953. Staline
enfermé dans son bureau l'a fait.  ne s'est pas présenté de
toute la journée son entourage n'a pas osé le
déranger
quand enfin le courrier du Kremlin
est entré dans le bureau il a trouvé Staline
inconscient allongé sur le sol
victime d'un grave
accident vasculaire cérébral son agonie a duré 5 jours il avait 75
ans Staline est mort le  de la même manière qu'il a
gouverné seul dans son
bureau,
l'homme responsable de la
mort de plus de 20 millions de personnes est mort au
sommet de son pouvoir, pleuré par
des millions de Soviétiques et même par certaines de
ses
victimes, il avait créé un système qui
lui survivrait.  depuis plus de 35
ans
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique] [
Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]